my guest tonight was a cast member on
saturday night live he also starred in
the film nebraska and the hilarious
series last man on earth
well now he's the voice of wolf tobin in
the great north which airs sundays on
fox
please welcome our old friend will forte
will
congratulations you got a lot going on
in your life what's happening
uh i just had a baby well well uh
my fiance olivia just had a baby yeah
you you did
very little there she did the work seven
weeks ago
uh february 15th her name is zoe douglas
forte
we love her and she was delivered by
a doctor named dr rad dr
rad dr rad r-a-d that's is that
his real name is dr rad yeah i mean he
might have had it you know maybe it was
dr radical
and he you know
he's a wonderful doctor but you can call
me dr
rad that's fantastic
and he was he's a good doctor i guess
he's a great doctor he did everything
that needed to be done and
and uh the baby's doing great and and
of course you'd get home and you're
getting tons of
of uh gifts from people baby gifts
people are sending food
but by far the best gift that i got uh
you know i'm a 50 year old father which
is pretty
old for uh father so my my olivia
had this made for me um
your fiance had this a sweatshirt that
says
dad or grandpa
[Laughter]
you're right on the line it could go
either way i've been this
this is touched off basically like all
the all the kind of
i mean i have a lot as you probably are
where i'm i'm a weird dude and and
have a lot of weird things about me but
but like i've one of the
problems i have is is i'm kind of a pack
rat
and i uh kind of i got way better about
it but then
this has just reignited uh you know
having
having this daughter has reignited
everything because i'm like i gotta i
gotta save everything
oh cause everything's a first you know
what i mean that's the thing
like so you feel sentimental about it
right yeah
exactly so i i you know in the hospital
it's gotten
so deep that it's like i after her first
poop i was like i gotta gotta save this
diaper right
and my fiance is like you're super gross
there's no way we're saving the diaper
so i finally
convinced her like oh would it make what
if we'd like saved it
to give as a good practical joke to a
friend
to a close a close friend and she said
you know begrudgingly agreed that it
would be a good joke
to to give somebody as a present and
then of course i got home and i was like
okay but maybe we should just keep it
for our files so we do have
we do have it's it's in a specimen oh
for god's sake why do you
have that that's terrible
no this is what if she what if she
somehow becomes
you know the first president of mars no
this is for that museum
no no no they're not going to want that
you got to get you got to get rid of
that
that's they don't want that then maybe
they'll want her umbilical cord oh for
god's sake
that's it you saved the umbilical cord
yeah you know what you can oh what's
your baby i also saved her baby
okay well the baby hat makes sense but
you don't want to know what's inside the
baby at them well
i'm guessing nothing's inside the baby
um
the umbilical cord you know what you can
do you can have it
uh put into jewelry did you know that
and wear it around your neck
you can have it you know put in like
some kind of glass or something and wear
it around your neck that's what you can
do
or i could poke holes in it myself and
just put a little string around it and
wear around
my neck for probably a way less of a
charge
right yeah it would cost less but it
would rot off of
your you know very quickly oh okay i
do want to save it uh you know the um
we went on a terrible cul-de-sac there
and i apologize to everybody yeah
horrible dad all right i'm gonna be the
most embarrassing yeah it's terrible
like here's her first tier
we made her cry on purpose so we could
save it uh
you know i would think now during kovid
and you know it feels like we're leaving
this covid period
i hope knockwood but uh
it's still we have still have to be
careful so i would think right now
baby photos are more important than ever
because you can't have family visit and
see the baby so you've gotta
you gotta send out that baby photo that
is crucial right now
oh yeah yeah the the uh i
i was kind of in charge of getting all
the pictures sent out i had a
text change to various people but but
the main text chain was obviously to
to my my family and i got in
a little bit of trouble um because at
some point
i i have a phone that is
has served me well but one of my dogs
knocked it out of my hand and so it had
a bunch of
squiggly you see all the squiggly lines
there on the side
oh it's got some it's got some yeah it
looks like cracks or something on it
yeah
yeah i mean it that just kind of
permanently showed up and wouldn't go
away and this was my fault the phone is
a you know it's a fine
phone i'm not doing an ad for a phone
but but like it was my fault the lines
showed up so i couldn't
i couldn't see everything they would you
know
so so there's one picture that i found
of my fiance
that was just the it was so delightful
and uh her and the baby
she can see oh she's right there yeah
what a beautiful photo that's very
beautiful yeah well what i wasn't aware
of
was that hidden behind these white lines
over here
was just her completely full nipple
oh my god and i sent that to
my mom and my dad my uh
brother-in-law my sister my niece and
nephew who are
like 11 and 10 laney and alden yeah
i've done to you well hold on and then
you had it made into a giant cardboard
cutout
and you're holding it up right now to me
you freak
what are you doing for attach this this
is going to be part of the umbilical
cord necklace i'm going to wear it
around my neck
so basically yeah you sent uh your
your fiancee's nipple out to a bunch of
young teens
is what you did unknowingly and she
she is a wonderful fiance because she
was like oh
you know i guess i guess everybody who
goes through
childbirth if you have not been
desensitized to having your nipples
uh out in public then you you kind of
get to that point yeah and she's there
but she was very
a very good sport about it uh well yeah
i'm glad i'm happy
for you that you've your your
relationship is still going strong
um you uh i know you're working right
now on the magruber tv series
you're working on that while you're not
getting sleep as a new
dad um let me ask you something about
that's always fascinated me about the
magruber film because there's so much
funny stuff in that movie
val kilmer i'm a huge val kilmer fan and
he was
a big part of the magruber movie
uh and plays the bad guy in it and um i
like i say
again i'm just gonna i've always been
i just i carry this you carry your
wife's nipple around i carry this photo
of val kilmer i'm such a fan
of his and i'm told that he can do it
all
he lived with you right you guys leased
to live together
yeah the uh it was after we made
mcgruber about two years after he was
selling his place in new mexico
and uh living in a place he was renting
in malibu
while he was waiting to get a different
place so he needed to stay with me while
he was
looking for a new place in malibu and
and so he asked if he
could save my place while he was doing
that it seemed like it was gonna be like
a two-day
experience and then on the second day
his assistant showed up with two just
enormous duffel bags filled with books
and
uh this is not a good sign for a quick
day he was there for the long haul he
was there for
like two and a half months three months
the most delightful experience it was
awesome yeah i would not trade it for
the world
did he ever morph into jim morrison
while he was living with you
that's what i would think would happen
if you lived with val kilmer
there was this one day when we were
sitting around it was like a saturday
morning we're sitting around my
my dining room table and he starts
playing uh
these uh his just music is playing along
from his computer
and a door song comes up
not only a huge doors fan but but
remember
i was at ucla when they were looking for
people for the
one of the concert scenes and i couldn't
i couldn't
be part of that but i just remember how
much i loved the dora's movie
and and the the crazy like thinking oh
20 years from now
i'm gonna have val kilmer who plays jim
morrison
sitting at my dining room table when a
doors song comes on
and he starts singing it was i think it
was la woman
and he starts singing along to the song
and i being a big
dora's fan started singing with him and
it was just this
moment i'll never forget after that
roadhouse blues came on so we
sang a couple doors songs together and
it's something i'll never
forget it's really awesome did uh do you
ever sing
would you ever sing a door song to your
daughter to get her to go to sleep
literally the first song that i sang to
her was really the
song called not to touch the earth
because it's the only song i think i
know
every word to and it it oddly it oddly
worked because i sing it softly but the
lyrics are you know uh toward the end
like
like like it starts out not to touch the
earth not to see the song
nothing left to do but run run run let's
run
but then it gets toward the end gets
kind of funky it's like
dead president's corpse in the driver's
car
the engine runs on glue and tar
come on alone what are you singing her
that for don't be singing that
it was the only one i knew all the words
to well don't sing that to your daughter
i'm sorry she's so far
has been unaffected by it she's still
you know i think a very normal baby
she has not said human words yet but i
think her first word is going to be
it's okay about the dora song
a phrase more than a word uh well now i
want to mention the great north the
great north
it airs sundays at 8 30 on fox are you
enjoying it's
it's you're you're working with uh nick
off for men this is very good cash
cockman jenny slater paul
like just a fantastic uh group of people
joel chase lone plays my
my beyonce excellent um and it's
it's been so great it's it's a little we
started the process before
kobed so we you know we were uh
getting to do a lot of the stuff
together um and then
since kova they they center in recording
equipment so you know it's not as much
uh
face-to-face yeah obviously but uh
hopefully
we'll get to be in a room recording
together again soon
all right we'll make sure i get the word
out the great north airs sundays at 8 30
on
fox will we're very happy for you
get some sleep when you can all right
i absolutely thank you yeah i worry
about you and
and the the the diaper get rid of it
just throw it out
right now no no no no no all right okay
that's great that's that's
that was the worst illusion i've ever
seen on zoom and that's really saying
something
i have been letting my magic slack a
little bit yeah it was bad
hey will thank you very much really
appreciate it thank you good to see you
good to see you